hannover damit kann herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal meine lieben freunde in dem ich
euch das neue merchandise vorstellen
wollte das soeben gelaunt des 19
ja also siehst du hier so das ist also
keine neue kleidung für die luke schwung
da genau also die sachen hier sind alle
gerade neu herausgekommenen luca shop um
15 uhr kapiert dass schon mal endlich
scheiße da ja also seit ein paar minuten
jetzt hier ist ja nicht schon alles
aussieht
du meinst soll dort als junger also um
auf deine frage zurückzukommen nein die
sachen sind noch nicht ausverkauft weil
wir von allen produkten hat genügend
bestellt haben
die einzigen sachen rostiger machst du
nicht sogar limited mit drop diesen
riesen und suchen ein jeder hat bei uns
die chance die produkte zu bekommen wir
haben möchte die einzigen sachen
limitiert sind sind die sachen von
unserem konto podcast merchandise haben
nämlich nur 1000 bestellt und 500 shirts
also das sind ja ja ja ja mein lieber
freund ich bin auf jeden fall sehr stolz
auf dich mein lieber mal her die sache
der neuen kollektion danke ludger also
ja das erste der fünf produkte die
soeben gelaunten luca shop ist dieser
schwarze rudy mit einem alpaka stieg
hier auf der brust und hier oben auf der
kapuze haben wir einen luxus stück drauf
dabei haben uns einfach gedacht dass wir
fast immer komplett beschissen aus hass
auch geile sachen zu mit bisschen zweck
und zu ja ich kann ja einfach mal
weitermachen mit dem nächsten produkt
uns war es dass ihr das zweite der fünf
produkte die soeben neu gelaunchten
lukasz ob das ist auch ein schwarzer
rudi der hat allerdings kordeln und auch
einen verwaschenen mai die print drauf
und hier unten haben wir ein umgekehrter
schrift wäre dass dies das dorf drauf
geschrieben weil ich das ja immer im
hintergrund von meinen videos auf dieser
leuchttafel habe also das ist ja
wirklich mega neu da fragen sich ja dann
freunde bestimmt auf entfernung
steht dort geschrieben und wenn sie dann
eher an mich herantreten lesen sie auf
dem pullover wäre dass diese stoffe also
da muss ich wirklich ein bisschen
schmunzeln muss ich wirklich zugeben -
seit jahren behindert ich etwas daran
lässt sich der garten als nächste
produkt ja okay also das hier ist das
dritte produkt das ist ein t shirt mehr
erzählt ich war etwas anders als sonst
steht ihr bald die stadt sehr viel
besser für mich weil ich so heiß ich bin
papa das jetzt auf jeden fall das t
shirt das hat vorne einen tick smiling
print und auf der rückseite auch wieder
den verwaschenen zwei liedern darunter
ein langer text dem hintergrund dass mit
dem inhalt dass man an sich glauben
sollte egal was andere leute über einen
sagen oder einem vorschreiben und hier
unten nochmal luca haben wir hier stehen
lupu was die ganze krankheit oder was
das ist der name seiner community user
community alter wissen welches oft sagen
die lustigen oder was ja ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir jetzt auf den
letzten beiden produkten kommen die
soeben neu gelauncht und luca schaffen
dass die offiziellen dick und doof
podcast merchandise produkte uns war es
das einmal dieser etwas eierschalen
farbige weiß rudi mit dem neongrün dick
und doof print drauf und auch
selbstverständlich ein t shirt wo wir
allerdings in roth sekunde eingesteckt
haben auf der brawn im t shirt wird es
500 stück geben und von dem rudi wird es
1000 stück geben was mal hässlich alltag
also ich finds gut luca auch die
qualität der sachen sie wirklich wieder
hammermäßig aus ich weiß nicht
produziert die noch in italien ja genau
also alles wurde wieder in italien
produziert weil qualität bei uns einfach
sehr groß geschrieben wird und dieses
jahr ist auch so gemacht dass wir von
jedem der fünf neuen produkte 200
autogrammkarten haben drucken lassen auf
denen ich drauf bin also bei den ersten
1000 bestellungen wird es auch noch eine
signierte autogrammkarte von mir dazu
gehen als man kriegt nicht nur ein
komplett beschissenes hässliches
merchandise sondern auch noch ein stück
pappe mit seiner unterschrift auf oder
was ja leider kein bock auf diese
scheiße hier die ganze zeit wenn wir
alles selbst machen die ganze wechsel
machen also ich finde es auf jeden fall
mega jolo was du da wieder auf die beine
gestellt hat luca und ich falte designs
und die qualität auch wirklich endstufe
also ihm bis heute auf jeden fall mal
unterwegs in lucka - shop.de ok ja dann
würde ich sagen schau dir doch auch gern
war jetzt direkt vorbei
[Musik]